this is what hacking looks like from
inside a computer system for real
this isn't Hollywood's Tron world or the
goofiness of an eighties film hacking
scene these graphics based on actual
computer traffic were commissioned by
DARPA the government agency that brought
us the self-driving car and the best
robot fails when it wanted to illustrate
a hacking challenge the right way it
turned to void alpha a Bay Area video
game company
I think the entertainment industry has
had various levels of success with this
it's a step that hasn't been taken is to
show what happens beyond the screen void
alphas graphics are critical to the
DARPA cyber grand challenge a fifty five
million dollar contest between seven
autonomous hacking BOTS battling on
seven supercomputers this August in Las
Vegas we haven't seen any real
representations of the logic and memory
of computers when they are being
attacked and when they are being
defended and that's something that we're
trying to do here for the first time
really but making AI versus AI was an
entirely new design challenge I'm used
to making games where people are
interacting with the computer and a
monitor is there so that a human can
interact with the computer but there's
no need for a monitor when it's
computers talking with each other so
we've had to come up with this visual
language of describing what's happening
visually inside of the machines the
visuals are look inside the computers as
the bots battle in real-time the most
dynamic view is called arena view at
where we just have a two-dimensional
card that represents each of the cyber
reasoning systems and on that card our
hexagons representing each of the
programs that the systems are fielding
protecting and running and then we have
spheres flying around representing
benign traffic in the network and cones
flying around representing the malicious
traffic in the network the shape and
size and look of each of the hexagons
changes to reflect other doing
and DARPA isn't just making hacking
visuals for the heck of it it's for your
entertainment and understanding when the
cyber grand challenge goes down it'll be
called like a sports cast by
commentators who practiced their calls
at a recent dry run so calling a game is
really mostly a matter of like
understanding the visualizations really
well and then being on your feet
reacting to what's going on I'm actually
really looking forward to the fact that
we we expect many emergent properties
that maybe even the teams didn't expect
to have occur where their system is
reasoning about a patch and can decide
to do it better than we've ever seen it
done before and that could lead to more
secure networks and Internet connected
devices if the technology developed here
can someday be as effective as a
real-world network response team then we
can turn those stories which are
something got breached months ago into
something got breached and we acted in
time to stop it in the future